after the worst flu season in nearly a
decade a new drug could revolutionize
how we treat the seasonal virus the FDA
agreed to fast-track a review of a drug
that shown impressive results in Japan
it is taken as a single pill and
shortens flu symptoms by more than a day
the drug also cuts the risk of spreading
the virus to other people our dr. David
agus is here good morning morning Vlad
so this is really revolutionary it's
exciting it's the first new mechanism
flu drug in over two decades and it's
one and done one pill and you know when
you get the flu virus it goes inside all
of the cells in your whole respiratory
tract and then they use them as a
factory this is the first drug that
actually blocks production of new virus
and so you take it in one pill and it
blocks the production of the virus and
shortens the duration of the flu it
makes you feel better
more effective than Tamiflu it's
different than Tamiflu in that they both
shorten duration by a day but this one
stops the virus from being spread after
one day whereas the Tamiflu it takes
three days and Tamiflu is twice a day
for five days a lot of people don't take
all of them and they don't remember yeah
this is one and done which when you'd
look at a public health that's exactly
how you want it meaning if I take it
maybe my family won't get sick too right
or you won't get sick at work or if
people have been exposed they take it so
this is a way of really hopefully you
know stopping the virus and it's tracked
I mean you saw entire schools closed for
days this year and kids dying to vaccine
then obviously children die and it's
horrible so is this one in done pill
expensive well it was approved in Japan
earlier this year and in Japan it costs
$43 for the pill what it will cost the
US we don't know the FDA has $43 for one
pill sound expensive it certainly does
but what a missed day of work is I mean
look at what days of workers look what
closing a school is so it's hard to know
in today's world you know unfortunately
it's not value-based and essentially
pharmaceutical mb's come up with the
price they want and see what the market
will bear but certainly we hope to have
an answer by the FDA by the end of the
year and then have this on the market
it'd be a hell of a Christmas present
for all of us so how soon could it be in
the US you think it'd be here by the end
of the year yeah so the FDA has agreed
to give an answer by the end of the year
it's already approved in Japan and so a
lot of the risk is taken away because
other regulatory agencies have reviewed
this pill it's safe
it really seems to work what does it
mean for the future of the flu vaccine
which everyone's still working on well
it means nothing is that you got to get
that flu shot it's still a lot better to
prevent the flu than it is to treat the
flu yeah but if you get the pill if it
comes here you don't have to get the
shot right no okay I was asking dr.
David agus Blatt and Nora gale you know
I finally got Gale to get her flu shot
right this year because after I Amy and
I shamed her into getting it because I
don't you rather be yes would you rather
be you know stuck in the toilet you know
for a couple of days they would rather
be a citizen yeah and then she went to
six different CVS but I'm proud of you
I'm Patti Thank You Nora name so this
will like the floor once you have it the
key is to prevent the flu get the flu
shot please all right dr. Lee nicely I
love having you at the table it's so
good to see you guys anything
[Laughter]